have you all gone out and actually
gotten supplies and food and water you
just watch we went to sam's club you
went to Sam's Club Raziel and no one
cares no one was there that's weird
actually you know what there was one
person that had two carts filled like
I'm talking mounds looked like like
Santa's sleigh filled the presents just
pushing I'm like what were they full of
food all serving food items yeah yeah
all sorts of food items man five five
bags of dog food on the underside which
is cool you know they're stocking up for
themselves in their chairs it's like but
it's a meal thing that breaks it he gets
it I just watched well we just were
playing the contagion have you ever seen
it I've seen it I know I haven't owned
the movie right yeah and so I thought
you said you were playing the movie okay
I was playing in the background without
I was playing in the background yeah
contagion is scary are they locked in a
building or no no no no it's it's it's a
whole bunch of different cast members
around the world dealing with the six
this virus that has a 33 percent
mortality oh I don't think I've seen
that it's like the CDC is trying to find
a cure for it Oh Milly er though well I
mean we're nowhere near 30 percent oh
that's pretty insane
but dude it was scary one thing that was
really confusing to me in the movie mmm
so basically the movie is a virus breaks
out people start having seizures and
dying they rush to try and find a
vaccine takes a long time by like 100
something days they've successfully done
it one scene that was really confusing
to me is because it's supposed to show
you how like the world is being affected
like the markets are slowing out and
crashing okay and there's a scene where
Jude Law's character who is this like
he's this guy who thinks he's got a cure
claims does he lives in San Francisco
and there's trash everywhere there's
people like lying in the streets
convulsing and he's wearing a hazmat
suit and I'm just like but that's just
like regular all San Francisco you know
I mean like I thought it was supposed to
show me a post-apocalyptic San Francisco
not what's actually like now I'm so
funny right so anyway now that I just
wasted a few minutes of your life and
and you deserve it we got a crazy story
man
where does I have no idea what this
means but a US Navy p-8a Poseidon was
lazed by a Chinese destroyer
so that's uh that's pretty crazy like
that's them aiming at us or is that them
actually attacking us I'm I'm I'm not
I do not believe right now militaries
are using directed-energy weapons yeah
yeah so I think this is a targeting
laser yeah they're laughing it they were
like locked on to whatever that is
probably because they you know wanted
them to know they were locking on
so they've yep get out of there dude
tensions has been crazy between the only
where was a long time where was it in
the self international no international
waters
oh wow maybe though where they're
claiming we own this this territory so
they're pushing their borders of the
water out they've been doing that yeah
and they're and they're setting up
military bases in the atolls in that
area they're putting planes all these
units stories are on these areas so
we've like a lot of people don't notice
how dangerously close we've been
teetering with like I don't want to act
like we're Washington say dangerous
dangerous Lee close but we've been
flirting China in the u.s. have not been
having a good time with each other
China is trying to expand they're doing
oil exploration they're setting up
competing interests the West weren't
they trying to make like a another
Panama Canal yeah the Nicaraguan canal
Nick around bail through as far as I
know okay but that was that would have
devastated when the largest freshwater
reservoirs in Central America and they
didn't care they were like we're gonna
plow through it wipe out all that
freshwater so what because they wanted
to shut down the Panama Canal which was
controlled basically like Western
interests yeah yeah so they've been
doing crazy stuff and the crazy thing is
with the coronavirus and now you know
all of the chaos in their country
economic slowdown supply chain
disruption factories being shut down
yeah they're full-on panicking and then
I'm looking at these stories and we'll
read the story about the Poseidon being
lazed cuz then actually explain what it
means and they expect us to just know I
guess like oh no one knows what lazed
means come on like I thought it was a
directed-energy weapon yeah an infrared
hit trying to like cause damage but
maybe but they say it's like it's it's
it's you know more of a nuisance that
could injure and harm vehicles so it
doesn't seem like it was an attack but
here's what scares what I've been
thinking seeing this story would China
in desperation seeing their economic
collapse they're losing the trade war
with us mm-hmm now they got this virus
spreading like crazy if they actually
think they're heading down the toilet
will they go nuts and try and take some
military gains to offset their massive
losses recently I don't know it doesn't
doesn't seem like something that a
country that's like
melting from the inside to go to war it
doesn't really I mean you said it's like
a resource thing they need resources but
aren't they using resources to sell us
the stuff that they're making no I mean
the factories have shut down right so
and they're and they're turning back the
masks that were produced in China so we
these n 95 masks that you need you know
they say don't you from a virus made in
China they're made in China well that's
what that's what I think the guy in San
Francisco they're like well he didn't
travel at all but it's like head did you
use any China Chinese scary though they
don't know that's all that matters I
mean but that makes sense you know you
made a joke that was like the family
guide or the Homer Simpson opened the
thing and it like shot on spam but it's
like that makes a lot of sense that
especial happen yeah but here's what
happened all of these masks were
departing the port in China and the
government turned it around and said
nope we get them so we need them now yep
so the factories in China took all that
money in from from companies here to
produce the masks oh and then channels
like we're gonna keep them because we
need them that's the stupidest thing
that the United States has ever done
it's been like we're gonna have a
foreign country produce our goods and
then what do you think happens mm-hmm so
actually let's let's let's read this
story and as we get in I'll do this as
well for those are listening live and
catch caught this live make sure you hit
the like button join if you'd like to
join and if you want to get your
comments read we'll do our best to read
the super chat sometimes it goes a
little fast for us but let's take a look
at this year's story
u.s. Navy p8 p-8a Poseidon lays to by
Chinese destroyer
they say they basically say the same
thing that was lazed by the People's
Republic of China Navy destroyer 161 On
February 17th while flying in air space
above international waters approximately
approximately 380 miles west of Guam US
officials revealed today so this
happened 10 days ago
Wow the p8 a was operating international
airspace in accordance with
international rules and regulations the
PRC Navy destroyers actions were unsafe
and unprofessional additionally these
acts violate the code for unplanned
encounters at sea a Mutua mute
multilateral agreement reached at the
2014 Western Pacific naval symposium to
reduce the chance of an incident at sea
sea ues specifically addresses the use
of lasers that could cause harm to
personnel or damage to equipment
the Destroyers actions
we're also inconsistent with a
Memorandum of Understanding between US
Department of Defense and the Ministry
of National Defense of the PRC regarding
rules of behavior for safety of air and
maritime encounters the laser which was
not visible to Nick to the naked eye was
captured by a sensor onboard the p8 am a
weapons-grade lasers could potentially
cause serious harm to aircrew and
Mariners as well as ship and aircraft
systems okay
weapons-grade what does that mean well
it it's not doesn't say that that's what
this was a weapons right it's right it
was oh yeah the Artic exactly it's not
saying that it was they don't know what
it was this is a trick they do in
journalism yeah exactly it make you
think this was a militaristic attack yes
yeah no I could see that my first
instinct was that it was targeted like
oh there's a ship there's a ship in our
airspace we're gonna target it it's like
they clearly knew they were targeted
they didn't fire on them because the
article doesn't say it was weapons-grade
it they just add that after the fact so
you assume that was the case there's a
little bit more they say the p8 a is
assigned to VP 45 based out of
Jacksonville Florida and is forward
deployed to Kadena Air Force Base in
Okinawa Japan
the squadron conducts routine operations
maritime patrol and reconnaissance in
the u.s. seventh Fleet area of
operations US Navy aircraft routinely
fly in the Philippine Sea and I've done
so for many years US Navy aircraft and
ships will continue to fly sail and
operate anywhere international law
allows u.s. seventh Fleet is the largest
numbered fleet in the world
with the help of 35 other maritime
nation allies and partners the US Navy
has operated in the indo-pacific region
for more than a century providing
credible ready forces to help preserve
peace and prevent conflict well I'll
tell you what man things have started
getting so crazy in China over the
expansion of this virus
you know there's this animation I don't
know if I don't know if you saw it
actually we're just talking about a
little while ago upstairs it shows all
of these other diseases and they're like
from day zero as they expand and then
when it gets to swine flu which is
really bad infected like 13 million
people coronavirus just skyrockets and
swine flu is going like slow like a slow
and steady rise no like I mean
technically but when you actually look
at the trajectory of swine flu it was
ridiculously fast so what scary asada
was and the moon and the more right and
the mortality rate was 0.5% oh man now
we have coronavirus and it's over 2% now
and it's growing away faster 2.2 percent
according to this chart as of the 41st
day so we're well beyond that now when
the chart ends we're looking at 40,000
people so that was the 41st day today
we're looking at 80 plus with 2200 dead
so I'm wondering you know I heard what
you were saying you don't think they
would they would escalate but I look
you've got all these contributing
factors mmm China's expansion this
they've they've constantly pushed our
buttons yeah and the big problem I think
the United States has had for the past
decades is the assumption that you can
you can appease or placate China and
they'll play they'll play by the rules
but they were at full health when
they've been poking us you know right
they're not at full health anymore
there's no Poconos
they just lazy and lazy I guess that's
true so that's what I'm saying like
could that break the back and then be
like we go all or nothing or do they
break apart and nothing you know could
this be severe enough so yeah we've got
the u.s. this is actually really funny
the US trade war unintentionally
prepared companies for the coronavirus I
thought this I thought it is interesting
it's true right everyone started I so
this is crazy to me and this made stuff
Donald Donald Trump was accused of
blundering and bumbling around with a
trade war causing all this harm but it
was forcing a lot of companies to start
bringing back trade to the United States
manufacturing I should say right then
the coronavirus breaks out you know we
stopped like making our own antibiotics
yeah in 2004 2004 that's how long ago
China's been making all of our
antibiotics all of them all of them and
China and India are the last antibiotic
like factory in America closed in 20
2004 so it's been 16 years since we have
had a factory that makes medicine for us
that's crazy
well aren't China yeah somebody was
messaging me saying that you know I talk
a lot about people should get food and
water mm-hmm but what about medicine
like what if you're that what if you're
diabetic yeah that's true stock up on
insulin man
I mean it needs to be referred to a
belief but III don't want it I don't
want to say go see the movie Contagion
like it's a pretty fun movie mm-hmm but
like it's pretty telling or what no no
it's like I don't want people to think
that's what's really gonna happen movie
because it's saturated yeah
but if that's what happens man it's
scary yeah it is
so like the main character is Matt Damon
his wife is Gwyneth Paltrow and then one
day she just dies oh wow and he's at the
hospital and they're like your wife is
dead he's like what do you mean we were
just eating dinner together yeah they're
like she's dead
and he's like no no what she was just
fine yeah and now she's like collapsed
and yep
so that this was a very severe disease
he was convulsing in the streets but
like pretty bad
I think people you know there's the
unthinkable 'ti biased there's the
optimism bias yeah it can never happen
to me things are gonna be fine
and then just everything falls apart
before people even realize it
yeah that's true now we're seeing that
that one that one food company a hundred
times demand yeah that's all there was
there was a good that there there there
that they exist let me see what I got
here so there's there's been big growing
concerns over conflict in the South
China Sea yeah and now it's coming to a
head with everything that's happening in
you know with with coronavirus yeah so
now with them still pushing on us this
is actually I feel like it's increasing
tensions because when you take the trade
war you take the existing conflict
between East and West China they've been
stealing on collateral property for what
decades they've been stealing TV shows
movies they have these weird knockoff
toys they sell yeah stealing our
technology then you then so you've
already had them in a really negative
position now we have now we have
basically the Chinese economy is like
taking serious hits yeah and I don't
think it'll ever get back to where they
were where they were making everything
because that's the way it trouble let it
know well I mean this is scary and this
is gonna it's not just Trump anymore I
think you know it's like he's the one
who's been spreading that message but
you know what their factories shutting
down a lot of companies are gonna have
no choice but to start looking elsewhere
yeah and then that's gonna be their new
system I mean shouldn't that have been
the case from the get-go though why
whatever make sense that we rely
how about we stop making antibiotics and
just let China do it this is the
craziest thing to me because cheaper and
the people that sell it make more money
that's literally it yeah but it's you
know it is it's the the people who ran
the United States it's we got there
there's a hole in the system in how our
government runs you get one dude in
office and his whole attitude is you
know what I can't change it screw it
I'll just do whatever I can to get that
sweet Chinese money right and so that
they start passing these bills and then
all of a sudden you start what while
we're engaging in these ongoing tensions
and escalation with China you know like
we mention the kurakin Canal yeah we
thought it was a good idea to continue
giving our manufacturing away to them
right like I was always I asked my
friend this years ago because we were
taught I was talking about talking to a
reporter about the Nicaraguan canal and
how they're trying to offset pan him on
all that stuff and people are like
what's the big deal because there was
also wrong this was before Trump and so
it was in the era of like negotiating
the trans-pacific partnership okay so
Obama and Hillary they wanted to have
this free trade agreement between you
know the US and and and the East Pacific
right sorry the West Pacific yeah yeah
and well actually no I think it is East
to them anyway whatever and people were
like so what it's free trades great it
boosts the economy and we heard all of
these things and I said what happens if
all of these tensions between the US and
China China just says we're going to war
and by the way all that stuff you gave
us money for we're gonna keep it yeah
now keep the money and keep this stuff
and then go to war with us and then
we're gonna use and then we can't make
antibiotics right and we have no masks
then we have no weapons then we have no
cars it's like we've given away
everything yeah it's crazy
that's scary it's like they didn't care
what actually happened in the United
States yeah we really gotta bring it
back I mean there's there's a rise of us
made stuff yeah I'm seeing it I have you
know I have a friend of mine who started
a clothing company and it's it's doing
so well and it's all American based it's
all really good quality stuff and that's
another thing it's quality that lasts
that's another thing people are getting
stuff that lasts now they're not getting
the cheap Chinese knockoffs you know
they're getting the they're spending
three times as much and having it last
ten times longer
that's how has always been well that's
how it used to be
I mean there was there were jokes and
like you hurry back in the day right no
before my time before I was even born
well actually no I was was born in the
early 80s so it's like I remember those
days of like quality stuff that you'd
get your one thing and that would be
your thing until it broke and you either
you try to fix it you didn't just go out
and get a new thing you fixed it made it
last longer you know we've we've fed
into this you know
it's like fast fashion also you know
it's the same kind of thing just replace
use it break it get a new thing isn't it
was good for the short-term gains mm-hmm
you know you know you know Dylan Ratigan
is mm-hmm I think this was Dylan Ratigan
no no this was maybe it was he said the
country's being extracted this was years
ago he went on this rant he used to he
was a report for MSNBC and he said
something like you know you got the
Republicans who want him who want him
What did he say he said the Republicans
want to burn it down and the Democrats
want to kick the can down the road for
next week generations while this country
he said it extracted right yeah it's a
good way of putting it though it makes
sense like that was happening like the
all the jobs were being sent overseas
our production our manufacturing and
everything was happening and this and
they have nothing but disdain for us
stealing our intellectual property and
then people in our government were just
basically alike works for me yeah it
these trade agreements make that money
well there's we're saving money we're
making more money and that's really it
is just whatever but yes you look at the
media and how they respond even to
coronavirus and I'm like they're
complacent and they're happy to be yeah
that's what room was it yeah he did say
it was being extracted tens of trillions
of dollars being extracted from the US
Democrats aren't doing it is is yeah
well anyways it's super old and viral
like well not super but but super viral
video yeah that was kind of old and
we're not when when when the coronavirus
came out were like when the news cited
breaking and I saw the reaction from a
lot of people in media was tepid and
they were like no no ignore it oh at
first the first stories I was like Keep
Calm we saw sorry summers and then it
started to get bad and I started to
monitor a lot of the stories you know
actual studies that had come out from
universities saying hey this thing's
questionable I immediately changed my
tone and said hey you know get ready
and there's still people in media
complacently laughing and gloating about
how smart they are yeah you know what
man I I it's it's this attitude that got
us in this position in the first place
where now we're gonna face a shortage
what was it
yeah Dylan Ratigan was talking about it
he goes Democrats aren't doing it
Republicans aren't doing it an entire
integrated system financial system
trading system taxing system that was
created by both parties over a period of
decades is at work in our entire country
right now we're sitting here arguing
about whether we should do the four
trillion dollar plan that kicks the can
down the road for the president in 2017
or burn the place to the ground both of
which are reckless irresponsible and
stupid so I appreciate his bar
bipartisanship because I'm seeing a lot
of partisanship right now that doesn't
make a lot of sense but think about what
happened since then Donald Trump got
elected yeah went nuts on China got
slammed for it and I think what ends up
happening is when you look at these
media companies they love to be the
ivory tower elites laughing how stupid
everything at how stupid they think
everyone else is yeah so coronavirus
hits and they're all like pinkies out
drinking tea Gwen oh the stupid peasants
actually think this will get bad and
then I'm watching and I'm like hey guys
gonna get bad I know what happens a
month later they're still like they
called Tom cotton a conspiracy theorist
yeah it's the same attitude that what
Dylan Ratigan was talking about the
extraction was these people sitting
around saying oh who cares if we give
our factories to a foreign country and
now here we are
we ordered masks to be produced for our
citizens China's like turn it around and
bring them right back to us and we paid
for and they look at us and and China
probably looks at that attitude and be
like that's America yo they don't care
they don't why why shouldn't we you know
that they have a word in China for like
social justice warriors whites wah
whites wah bytes wah it means white left
and dude they're super racist justice
work and they know that our country has
a problem with a bunch of we have a
bunch of whiney sensitive babies yeah I
love talking about the baby millennial
problem yeah and then we also have a
bunch of people who are so extremely
selfish yeah and lack community that
they're like they get in office and they
say what can I do to enrich myself while
I'm here yeah who cares about anything
else like you you've mentioned multiple
times that this is basically the new
civil war right we're we've
everyone's feuding in America like I I
don't even think about outside America
and we're basically in a little mini war
right now trying to figure out like what
to do where to where to go in our
political system this weekend we're
screwed it's a pretty opportune moment
for China attack it actually makes sense
because we are divided we're like or or
they've been we've been dealing with
cyber attacks for a long time mm-hmm but
they don't need to anymore right what's
the what's the point of an actual
physical conflict it's it's like when
all else fails yeah you're right why
wouldn't they just inject coronavirus
into all of our antibiotics that we get
well well I don't know about that but
what I'm saying that's the physical
attack okay okay what I mean is they can
sit back as we tear each other apart
give it a few years on a suit and we're
being extracted and they're getting our
late hour our labor our manufacturing
yeah so they were winning without ever
having to land a soldier on a beach yes
so why would they even yeah I even like
why what is a plane well cuz now Trump
has basically put a spike in it yeah he
said yep we're gonna tax all your stuff
and we're gonna bring it back to America
basically so this is the thing right he
likes to say that it's the taxes the
tariffs from them mm-hmm when a product
gets brought into the u.s. that the US
company pays the price and then jacks
the price up on the people right but it
is a deterrent mm-hmm so you have right
now with coronavirus you've got you've
got pilot you got the you got his
opponents trying to point the finger and
weaponize everything against them
yeah not what we're screwed like it's
it's it's mind-numbing to me that you
can't give Trump one good day yeah
Elizabeth Warren did said something
about like they asked her every what she
you know what would she do and she said
well I would I would take all the money
from his racist wall and use it Albert
and I was like why do you Eve every
single chance is an attack you know it's
like okay there's no unit so it doesn't
make any sense I I get that you don't
like the wall man yeah exactly no beef
no beef but we're talking about the
coronavirus Trump virus yeah they're
yeah they're calling it the Trump virus
I can't believe it but but this is but
it's it's not so much like I don't want
to make it get into the politics of it
no no but it's an issue of can we as a
country survive
on this path I will say I think right
now the culture war not the president
the president is a symptom of it not the
cause or solution to a lot of people
think so
this something happened where the
pendulum started swinging so hard there
was like a hard stop for a lot of people
and it was you know it resulted in
Donald Trump for one but how much longer
could this could United States go on
giving away the manufacturing base
sending its plants overseas bringing in
non-citizen labour displacing the
American worker and then telling all of
the young people to take on massive
student loan debt for a degree that
won't get him a job all I see is all the
people in charge all the people that
already own stuff just making more money
that's what it was now now well the
calling of that blue collar boom well
the system is is all falling apart now
and you know people are getting getting
woke too for lack a better word you know
that's what's happening there to all the
stuff that that they've been looped into
you know the college crazy the yahoos in
our factories and again like I think I
think the president is a symptom of
what's going on not in the cause or
solution I think you know people voted
for him for a lot of reasons but it was
the people themselves are trying to wake
up to this start to make these changes
mm-hmm rejecting certain like the
pendulum swung too far and yeah like
Dylan Ratigan said the country was being
extracted by this large machine you know
and if people eventually said enough you
know and now the Democratic
establishment so the Republican
establishment was just crushed yeah you
know the insurgent Republican you know
Trump base came in now you have the
Bernie side trying to crush the
establishment on that side and that's
falling apart and I think I don't know
where this ends but my concern is China
has been able to grow exponentially off
of the extraction on the United States
and it's not only to China but they got
a ton of our labor like you know Mexico
and some other India was getting a lot
of our work and our money and go does
China react now as everything falls
apart on their end with now is our
chance to make a move we have no choice
what do they do or it's more like we
need to make a move now before we
crumble right completely because the
tariffs the trade war you know they're
losing yeah exactly and so now it's like
they're losing their hold on the world
yeah yeah that's scary
the coronavirus scares me
this regard because if it really does
become something really really bad like
I'm not saying the world can and I'm not
saying we're gonna end up in a war the
issue is that we've got all these
factors straws in the camel's back that
have been pushing us into conflict with
China right if coronavirus really does
like you know get worse than swine flu
because those graphs are looking like
it's gonna be worse does China go so
desperate that they say you know they
throw all reason to the wall they with
reckless and abandon charge straight in
and just go nuts lays one of our ships
or do they humble themselves and ask for
help
yeah that's that's that that's that's
that's the right question do they then
say you know what we just can't we can't
deal with this and then bend the knee
yeah that'd be funny if Trump came out
and he was like and we'll help you then
and then ji Jinping does that would be
crazy
that'd be a crazy thing thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you